in this specific instance where you want
to raise it you want to negotiate or
bring up the notion of a race I think a
you have to look at the conditions of
the playing field right which is you
know what's the state of the company
what's the state of the industry is it
in retraction or is it an expansion you
know typically obviously when times are
better and the organization is doing
well there are greater opportunities to
ask for a race and put yourself in a
position where you can get a raise you
know that there are two camps here
they're sort of I call them zeros and
ones there are people whose eros who
just put their head down do a good job
and expect the company to look after
them from a compensation perspective
there are the ones I call them flame
chasers that are out there it doesn't
matter what they do they want more money
and they wanted a gold star right and I
don't think either one is correct I
think what you need to be is somewhere
in the middle which is yes you need to
put your head down yes you need to do a
good job yes you need to get noticed but
then you need to at the appropriate time
you know not when the company's cutting
20,000 employees and in total retraction
but when the conditions are right and
they're getting more right as we move
into 20 11 and 12
you know start to have conversations
with your boss and really start the
conversations around additional
responsibilities roles that you're
interested in broader roles inside the
organization because with role and
definition of role and broader
definition of role often comes
compensation so you know you can go
right at the heart sometimes you just
need to you know in your in your
one-on-one with your boss have a
compensation discussion and bring up the
idea of salary and you can benchmark
yourself against the external world and
say look I've fallen behind here's what
my peer group makes I feel like you know
I'm doing a great job I've done X Y & Z
and come factually relevant with your X
Y & Z and have that calm conversation or
you can go the route of you know
additional responsibilities broader role
new role which again often opens up the
discussion around compensation and when
you have a mechanism like role or
responsibility to open up the discussion
then you can come into that not looking
like a meat-eater that is only one that
only wants is only about money but you
come in through a facilitated discussion
and then have a meaningful discussion
about your compensation going forward